carrie fisher's cause of death revealed  the LA County Medical Examiner's Office  confirms to ET that Kerry died of sleep  apnea and other undetermined factors  heart disease and drug use were also  among the conditions that led to her  death Kerry's daughter Billie lourd  released this statement to ET quote my  mom battled drug addiction and mental  illness her entire life she ultimately  died of it she was purposefully open in  all of her work about the social stigmas  surrounding these diseases I know my mom  she'd want her death to encourage people  to be open about their struggles be real  and not get too wrapped up in it the  iconic Star Wars actress died nearly six  months ago after going into cardiac  arrest on a flight from London to Los  Angeles she was 60